so we begin with breaking news the US
military says that the houthi armed
group has struck a us-owned container
ship off the coast of Yemen the strike
caused minimal damage to the jalter
eagle which continued its Journey the
incident was first reported by the UK
Maritime authorities let's get the
latest on this from Mike Hannah in
Washington DC Mike tell us what you
know well centcom the Su Central Command
has also said confirmed that there is
little damage to the vessel there are no
injuries and it is continuing on its
Journey uh just to repeat what sencom
initially uh reported on January the
15th at approximately 400 p.m. Iranian
Ved houti militants fired an anti-ship
ballistic missile from hooti controlled
areas of Yemen and struck the jalter
eagle a Marshalls Islands flagged us
owned and operated containership now it
also says that earlier in the day there
was an attempted missile attack on a US
Destroyer in the Red Sea uh the missile
was shot down by a us fighter aircraft
so a series of events happening in the
Red Sea in the course of the day and
this is particularly important uh given
the fact that the US and UK aircraft
struck at more than 60 Targets in the
areas com controlled by the hooes in the
past few days now us officials have said
that they estimate that the hooti still
retain some three4 of the ability to
launch Miss Iles or launch drones so
obviously the events of the morning have
borne this out that despite these air
strikes uh the attacks on shipping in
the Red Sea continues despite warnings
from the US that they will respond if it
does
so Mike help us understand something um
bad pun but help us navigate this issue
again sorry bad pun how is the
US balancing interests between not escal
escalating hostilities in the region
they say they do not want an escalation
and they do not want a wider war in the
Middle East and then at the same time
they want to protect this Waterway and
therefore neutralize the houthi ability
to attack these
ships it's a very complex situation one
that the US may be struggling to
navigate as you put it uh but yes one of
the US's greatest concerns is the
escalation of the violence that has been
continuing in Gaza and the occupied West
Bank now the houis carrying out these
attacks are linking it to what is
happening in Gaza the US is attempting
to distance itself from that portraying
this as basic acts of piracy on shipping
in the Red Sea now the US says it does
not want a widening of the conflict
however at the same time as you
mentioned it does want free traffic
passing through the Red Sea where a huge
amount of container traffic passes
including vital energy resources for the
US and indeed other countries across the
globe but at the same time it's got to
retaliate it appears to believe so it is
walking this very fine tight rope in
terms of not allowing the conflict to
widen and at the same time not to be
seen to be waving a stick and then not
actually punishing anybody for the
ongoing attacks on shipping in the Red
Sea so you do have a very complex
situation here and one must remember too
that they carrying out these attacks
along with the UK on houti um targets it
is said but at the same time one must
remember that the hoties have been
involved in a war for several years and
Saudi back forces have not been able uh
to stop their operations so very
unlikely that us and UK action would
succeed where several years of war has
failed now Mike Hannah reporting from
Washington DC thank you very much
just moments ago UK prime minister Rishi
sunak addressed Parliament over his
country's participation in strikes
against houthi Targets in Yemen he
denied that the armed groups campaign
had any relation with the ongoing war on
Gaza Mr Speaker we shouldn't fall for
their malign narrative that this is
about Israel and Gaza they target ships
from around the world we continue to
work towards a sustainable ceasefire in
Gaza and to get more Aid to civilians we
also continue to support a negotiated
settlement in Yemen's Civil War but I
want to be very clear that this action
is completely unrelated to those issues
it is a direct response to the hooti
attacks on international
shipping all right Harry faet joins us
live from London Harry bring us up to
speed on the UK's role in all of this it
it seems a little bit like a two-man
team I know there's a wider Coalition
but it seems a little bit of at the
moment especially the last few days like
a two-man team between the US and the UK
to in their words protect the Red
Sea yes when this strikes happened uh UK
time Thursday night overnight into
Friday uh there was talk of this being a
a multi-nation effort they talked about
support coming from Canada Australia and
others and and there being part of the
The Wider 20 Nation Coalition uh
operation Prosperity guard Ian as it's
been christened by the the US military
um but yes when it came to the strikes
essentially they were us strikes with a
relatively small amount of UK support
for typhoon aircraft uh flying out of
the RAF Airbase in Cyprus Rich act
telling Parliament that the 13 strikes
13 targets that were struck were
successfully destroyed and that there
were no known civilian casualties that
there was care that these were military
targets and so essentially there three
things he was saying the first being
what you just heard uh that this was a
response to a threat uh against us
interests and against global trade uh he
said it was self-defense and unrelated
to the war in Gaza uh saying that people
shouldn't fall for the malign as he
called it houy narrative uh he was also
saying that this was not escalatory this
was limited and proportional uh an act
of self-defense and he also was
responding to any queries that people
might have had about the fact that this
was taken this action without uh a
debate let alone a vote in Parliament
ahead of time uh saying that because of
the operational security uh of the
imminence of the threat uh that he had
to take the decision uh as in the hours
before it happened on Thursday but that
he briefed the Speaker of the House of
Commons the leader of the house and the
um and the leader of the opposition as
well and so he took the necessary
measures he is saying uh to uh inform
everybody that needed to be informed and
it must be said the main opposition
labor party is supportive of the action
as well okay Harry fet reporting outside
the houses of Parliament in London uh on
those L latest statements by the British
prime minister thank you very much I
want to take that studio now to rasul
SAR who's joined us uh you've reported
on this region in this region before
it's interesting we have two completely
different narratives at play here from
the first first day that they started
attacking ships in the Red Sea the
houthis in Yemen said we are doing this
in support of Palestinians in Gaza and
against Israel's war and we hear the
British and the Americans saying don't
believe that it's got nothing to do with
that we're just in it to protect ships
to protect freedom of navigation two
competing narratives indeed I hu is
definitely will not agree with what the
British prime minister has just said so
from the first day on when they started
attacking some ships they made it quite
clear that they their aim is not to
block the this this Maritime passage but
rather to stop the ships that are going
to Israel or coming from Israel or owned
by Israeli businessmen just to stop them
and that was the the the the stated
purpose and they said we do not want to
go beyond that so that's why they were
trying to create a de facto situation
and set a new rule that each of the
container ships that is passing through
the Red Sea needs to contact them and
give them the clarification and the
guarantee is that they are not having
anything to do with Israel so that is
their condition but on the other hand
some of the people that are uh familiar
with the matter say that actually
practically that's going to be quite
difficult because for the containerships
the way that they work it's not like
they just get their loads from a certain
location and then take it all the way to
a certain Market actually they drop the
loads gradually
in different ports so it means that
these ships that are going to Israel
actually are going to several other
ports as well so practically once you
say that you're not going to go to the
port of Elliot for example you are
actually Banning the ships who go to the
European markets as well so if the
houthis are they say they're blockading
Israel and the Israeli ports what you're
telling us is when you do that you're
also essentially blockading all the
other ports indeed so but on the other
hand we have seen that narrative is is
quite important for the UK and for the
USA saying that this has no connection
with the war in Gaza but rties have been
insisting on that so that's why many
people are now criticized in the US and
the UK saying that if you really want
the freedom of the navigation across the
Red Sea the practical way that you can
solve that problem is actually to put an
end to the war that's going on in Gaza
put pressure on Israel to stop its War
because during the ceasefire one we
ceasefire whoi sto their attacks on the
ship so that will be much more
effectively in instead of striking Hui
Target in Yemen because so far we have
seen that USA was in a defensive
position attacking the houthis in Redi
but then they took it to the next next
level and started to attack the houi
targets within Yemen which is now almost
becoming a regional war and hudis are
now saying that if that continues they
are going to turn the Red Sea into a
burning Arena which probably they are
quite serious because as of now we see
that the UK and the US air strikes have
not been able to deter houthis so here
I'm not expecting that houthis are going
to retaliate big time or dramatically
however the psychological environment
that they have created is having a huge
impact on the global Maritime trade so
as of now this is what Americans are
accepting and saying that at least 40%
decrease in the maritime um trade across
the Red Sea and that is quite huge we're
talking about billions of dollars just
considering the fact that more than 12%
of the global Maritime trade is just
happening through Babel mandap trade so
I don't see that anytime soon H is are
going to be deterred not expecting any
huge dramatic retaliation however this
harassment is going to be there and
probably USA also is going to increase
his the frequency of his attacks on H
Target in Yemen all right so incremental
escalation incremental retaliation is
what you're expecting rasul Sardar thank
you very much